- There are people with incredible talent
and no motivation and then
there are other people
that are willing to work their ass off.
It's above winning a contest.
It's about that one time
just, yeah I did that!
This is what I love
doing more than anything
and I would do it for free.
Any day of the week.
There were times when I
started our company, Birdhouse,
in the first three years in,
we were ready to give in.
He's an American professional
skateboarder, actor,
and owner of the skateboard
company, Birdhouse.
He's widely considered
to be one of the pioneers
and most successful influencers
of modern vertical skateboarding.
Throughout his career,
he's made a number of appearances
in films, other media,
and his own line of video games.
He's Tony Hawk and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Tony's talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(upbeat music)
- It wasn't until I started
my own team when I realized
that there are people
with incredible talent
and no motivation and then
there are other people
that are willing to work
their ass off who don't have
a natural ability but
will become successful
because they're so determined
and I saw it especially
in a couple of guys
that I first put on the Birdhouse team,
namely Andrew Reynolds, Matt Beach.
Matt Beach was, in my eyes,
the most naturally talented skateboarder
that I've ever seen.
Everything came easy to him and, you know,
when I would request
these guys to go on tour,
all I ask of them is that they skate
for exhibitions and whatnot.
Matt wouldn't skate half the time.
I flew him to Europe.
I didn't have any money
then in our company
but I was flying these guys
to Europe for competitions.
He would go to the contests
and not feel like skating
and I was like, how can you do that?
You know, I was thinking, not
just to me but to yourself.
You have this incredible
talent and you just don't care
and then I saw Andrew
Reynolds who was this scrappy
little guy taking not very
clean in terms of his style
but trying some of the hardest stuff,
taking the heaviest hits but
always skating his ass off
and always trying and
he has become probably
the most well respected
street skater today.
Andrew Reynolds, I mean
he formed Baker Brand,
Deathwish Skateboards.
The community of the most
hard core skater these days
call him The Boss because
he developed his style
because he worked his ass off
and he's the shining example
of hard work.
- [Announcer] Tony Hawk is
the number one recognizable
sports figure over Shaq,
over Iverson, over MJ even.
- I just focus on something
and I have to do it.
I'll either get hurt, taken
to the hospital trying it,
or I'm going to make it and
that was the same for doing
the 900 at the X Games.
It was my time to finally
do it or to be carted off
and tried another day.
- [Announcer] Last try
right here, Tony Hawk, 900.
- At some point, you
just tune everything out
and you say this is it, you got to do it.
- [Announcer] Literally,
Pier 30 shook and we felt
the ground swell.
I wasn't sure if it was an
earthquake or somebody out there
doing something special.
That moment was probably burned
in most of our minds forever.
- I knew I wanted to be
in the skating industry.
I loved skating too much.
I wanted to be in it.
I didn't know if I would make
a living as a professional
but I was going to be, I was
devoted to skateboarding.
So I refinanced my house
and took all the money
and started a skateboard
company which seems like
the stupidest thing in the
world to do when skating's dying
but it was exactly what I wanted to do.
I wanted to be a company owner
and be behind the scenes.
I quit my sponsor and started
and for about three years,
struggled very hard with my partner and I,
we had pooled our money together.
He was an ex-pro skater as
well and we just did Birdhouse
and did whatever we could
to get by and all the team
was staying on my couch.
I literally, while I'm changing diapers,
I'm like driving guys to these
spots that they're going to
get arrested at because
there's no skate parks
so they're going to go ride schoolyards
and it was such a strange existence
but I loved it because
it was skateboarding
and it was exactly what I wanted to do
and so we really hunkered down.
I was living on Taco Bell
and peanut butter and jelly
and Top Ramen.
- Yum.
- Probably three years, for sure,
but I didn't care 'cause it was like,
I still got to do what I love.
That's the thing is that people think,
was it a struggle?
And it's like well, no,
because I loved it too much.
I still got to go skate
and I had time to skate.
I didn't have to go sit behind
a computer for eight hours
and then hope I get time to skate.
- [Male] Okay, ready and action.
- [Male 2] Three, two, one.
Go!
(rock music)
(crowd cheering)
- Alright, guys.
- I'm glad you're alright.
- Let's not do that again.
(group laughing)
- [Male] I agree.
(rock music)
- [Group] Oh!
- That's great.
(rock music)
- I know there are so many
kids out there that feel
the way that I did when I was a kid,
just awkward and not excelling
at one thing in particular
and not cool and skateboarding
was my way out of that
and I hope that, if
not with skateboarding,
they find it with something else they do
but I hope that they're not afraid
to try something
different 'cause you can't
listen to the haters.
That's my best advice to anyone.
If I had listened to the haters,
I would have quit a long time ago.
I would have quit when I was 11 years old.
I used to get bashed
by professional skaters
because my style was
dorky or it was all circus
but you can't.
You've got to believe in yourself.
As far as I know, no one's
done anything like this,
and so people keep
asking me questions like,
well, how do you approach it?
I don't know.
I'm just going to find
out the hard way, I guess.
It feels like the first
time I tried the loop.
I just walked up to it and was like, holy,
what have I done?
But I'm up for the challenge.
(upbeat music)
Whoo.
Second try.
I can't throw that up.
("Somebody Grab the Wheel")
(crowd cheering)
- Yeah, I think Tony's going to do it.
I think it's just going
to be hanging that angle.
- That was like a half head,
half knee slide but hey,
I didn't hit my hip so success.
Okay, get these pads out of here.
- It's coming down.
He's got it.
("Somebody Grab the Wheel")
- Here we go.
(crowd cheering)
- I'm just so excited.
I can't believe it worked.
- [Pharrell] Does running
the Tony Hawk empire
give you the same
satisfaction as the nine golds
at the X Games?
- I love the challenge of
the business aspects of it
but I love that it's still fun.
- Yeah.
- I mean, the stuff that I
choose to do is only stuff
that I really am
passionate about and stuff
that I will enjoy seeing through.
To be honest,
the high that I go for
that is always driving me
is when I land something new,
when I'm trying to learn a new trick
and I make it for the first time,
even if it's something
someone else has already done,
for me, that push and that
adrenaline and the confidence
of thinking I can do this
and then finally doing it,
you know, seeing it
through and when I land it,
that's the buzz, that's the
high for me above all else,
above winning a contest.
It's about that one time
just, yeah I did that!
- Yeah.
- And I'm older now and now
when I get that feeling,
it's further between when
I feel it and so when I do,
it's way more intense.
- It's like landing your first kick flip.
- It's, yeah, that's what it feels like.
Every time.
It doesn't look as intimidating
when it's not sitting
on top of a building structure.
The jump is always scary
'cause you want all your skin
anywhere on your legs covered.
- [Cameraman] Are you sure
it's just not for fashion?
- Well, that too.
This is my mega board.
- [Cameraman] Mega.
(wind blowing)
Whoo!
Yeah!
- I did it!
(cameraman laughs)
I wanted to figure out
how I could remove myself
from competition and still be a pro skater
and that had not been done yet
because if you're not going to compete,
the magazines aren't going to cover you,
your sponsors are likely
to drop you and the kids
who are buying your products
are going to forget about you
and there was no such thing
as a video skater back then.
That hadn't really come into play yet.
- Mm Hmm (affirmative)
- There was no YouTube.
The skate videos were usually
based on the best guys
in the competitions and so
I went and talked to Stacy.
- Who was your boss at the time?
- Stacy Peralta was my coach
and I actually had my brother
come with me as back up and
he approached Stacy and said,
"Look, Tony's really having a
problem with the competitions.
"It's kind of wrecking him.
"It's ruining the fun of skating."
And I told him that and so he said,
"Well, I understand.
"Maybe you might want to take a break
"but don't give it up completely
"'cause you may want to come back.
"You may enjoy it and I
don't know if we're going to
"be able to sustain your career
if you're not competing."
And I did take a break.
I stopped competing for
awhile, almost a year,
maybe a little less and
when I came back to it,
I came back with sort
of a fresh perspective
that I don't really care how it lays out.
I'm going to go and do my best
and I'm going to take chances
that I maybe hadn't taken
before and if that puts me
in last place then so
be it but if I succeed,
I'm going to be on this
whole other level of skating.
- Mm Hmm (affirmative)
- And that's what happened and
the contests that I won then,
I won by a long shot
'cause I was doing stuff
that was experimental and stuff
that I wasn't really confident
with but I could pull it
through somehow and if it didn't happen
then I didn't do well at
all and I stopped caring
about the end result so much.
("Police Truck" by Dead Kennedys)
- What is it that makes
you real special --
- Well, for one, I never quit.
I never stopped skating.
So, I never took a hiatus, say
five years and came in like,
oh, skating's hot now I'm
going to get back into it.
So I had that consistency
but I think that, for me,
I really liked learning new
techniques and a lot of people,
they did their skating sticking
with this one style of skating,
this one set of tricks and
don't want to branch out
because they're afraid
they won't look cool
doing it or whatever.
I always wanted to try
the different techniques
even if I stumbled on 'em.
I knew that in the end it would
help me be more well rounded
and I think that's probably
what it is that I just wanted
to try to learn it all.
- [Announcer] Going for something big.
He's going for a flip.
He's going for something new.
Crowd seems to be
anticipating something good.
(crowd cheering)
We've seen that he can
fly high and here it goes.
Here's Tony!
He's in the water!
Takes a swim.
(crowd cheering)
And the crowd loved that.
That skateboard's gone.
Actually, they'll be a few
people diving in there,
trying to fetch that one.
Tony Hawk.
- What the heck kind of move was that?
- I don't know, it's the
big gap to the snake canyon.
- A brand new move by
Tony Hawk into the water.
- [Announcer] Tony Hawk,
always a crowd pleaser
and no exception there
and Tony Hawk set off
at a blistering pace.
He had to clear the dock
and cleared it by a mile.
What a performer.
(crowd cheering)
See it from behind again.
Scooting his way across
the arena, off that ramp,
hit it at the diagonal.
Wonderful stuff.
What an end.
- If you're convinced
that you're going to fail
or fall or get hurt,
that will come to fruition
because that's what
you're visualizing.
I never, I was willing
to get hurt along the way
but I didn't visualize myself
getting hurt along the way
and I think that's what
stops a lot of people
and that's really what
separates a lot of people
from being world champions or
from being as good as they can
because they stop at some point saying,
"Oh no, I'm not capable of this,"
or "I'll probably get hurt doing this,"
and if you approach anything
with that hesitation,
you're going to fail.
I always approached it
like, this is going to work.
I'm going to figure this
out even if it takes me
hundreds of attempts
and I wasn't, the idea of falling
and getting back up again,
that didn't really bother me at all.
(rock music)
I don't really need the money.
I don't need the money anymore.
I made dream money from
video games, like stuff,
things that I would never imagine.
When people say, "Is
this what you dreamt?"
I didn't dream any of this.
None of this was possible
or even considered a reality
when I was a kid.
When I started skating,
the best you could hope for
was your picture in a magazine,
maybe a pro board, maybe, and free gear.
That's it and then once you
reach an age of responsibility
and this is I'm talking
about when I was like 12,
once you reach an age of
responsibility say 18,
your career is over 'cause
you can't make money doing it.
You can't do it into your adult life.
Obviously, I'm hugely
thankful to still be able
to do this for a living.
This is what I love
doing more than anything
and I would do it for
free any day of the week,
at any given time.
I'd happily just go skate.
It just happens to be the
thing that I'm successful at
so I get to do what I love for a living
and that's living the dream.
I mean, living the dream,
I'm not talking about financial success.
I'm talking about loving what you do.
If you love art and you
do art and maybe you get
a little bit of success at it,
you're living the dream.
(punk music)
There were times when I
started our company, Birdhouse,
in the first three years in,
we were ready to give in.
The sales just weren't there.
The interest wasn't there
and same with my skating.
I was still improving my
skills but for no audience.
So it was definitely
difficult but we embraced
those challenges too and
especially as athletes,
someone poses a challenge to
you and you have to figure out
how to get over it and so in doing that,
in my skating and also in the
business it was like, well,
this is what's coming at us.
We've got to figure out
how to navigate this
and how to succeed and a
lot of people just give up
and especially in skating, I mean,
that's the first sign
of someone that's going
to be successful is no matter how far,
no matter how successful they
get especially in competition,
they continue to challenge themselves
because they want to improve.
Those are the guys that
make it way further
than anyone else.
(punk music)
(crowd cheering)
- Your Honor,
I'm here on behalf of the
great state of Alabama
to prove once and for all
that skateboarding is, was,
and always has been a
crime and that this man,
Anthony Francis Haywood Beauford Hawk,
should be found guilty of perpetrating
the most gnarly of offenses.
- Mr. Hawk, would you like
to make an opening remark?
- Yeah, I guess that I think
skateboarding is not a crime.
- There is no half pipe that
can launch you out of hell.
(crowd clapping)
- And what was Mr. Hawk doin' at the time?
- He was riding one of
those planks with wheels.
- Objection.
Skateboarding is allowed in public areas.
- Well, I just thought that
doesn't seem like something
you should do.
(crowd clapping)
- Mr. Hawk, how long have you been riding
these devil mobiles?
- Pretty much my whole life.
- Let the record show that Mr.
Hawk was carving a pentagram
into his chest as he answered.
- No, I wasn't!
- Let me ask you something, boy.
- I'm in my mid-40's.
- If God had intended us to skateboard,
why wouldn't he have blessed
us with wheels instead of feet?
- I don't know.
- Why did he give us
legs instead of trucks?
Or why did he not put
little decals of skulls
on our bellies or put
adhesive tape on our back?
- I get it.
- As the Bible says, Lo,
and man shall not step on a wheeled plank.
- Revelation 20:13.
- Now, I personally can't
think of anything more sinful
than somebody launching off
a vert ramp into a kick flip
mctwist but for those who need convincin',
maybe you could enlighten us, professor.
- I've discovered several
eyewitness accounts
of skateboarding at some of
history's greatest crimes.
This is a picture of Tony Hawk
high fiving Adolph Hitler.
- That's obviously doctored.
- This is Tony doing what
appears to be an ollie
off the balcony moments
after Lincoln was shot.
- This is insane!
- And this is Tony grinding down the tail
of a dinosaur moments
before the meteor hit
that exterminated all dinosaur
life on the planet earth.
- Well, that one's kind of true.
- Well, I invented the railing to provide
a stable grabbing surface for God fearing,
stair climbing men and women,
not to be grinded on by
some immorale beast trying
to pull off a frontside board slide.
Nothing human uses a railing like that.
You have disgraced my work, sir!
You have disgraced the
work of Phineas Q. Railing.
- I rest my case.
- I find you guilty, Mr. Hawk,
and declare skateboarding a crime!
- You can't!
- Would you like to say
anything before I pass sentence?
- There's nothing else
you could do to me, sir.
- I hereby sentence you to change
to a respectable mode of transportation.
- What's that?
- Bring in the scooter.
- Lame!
Alright, today is June 27th,
2016 and it is 17 years
to the day that I landed
my first 900 at the X Games
in San Francisco.
A lot has happened since then in my life.
I mean, it's been the
craziest roller coaster ride
and it really was the apex
of my competitive career.
So I'm going to try a 900 today
because I feel like I can and
I never thought I'd be doing
this at my age when I was young.
I really didn't think
that was a possibility
but I'm still goin' and
keep goin' 'til the wheels
fall off I guess.
(bleep)
(group cheering and clapping)
Spencer was there on my first one
and now he was on my last.
Bye.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
VenomLeon asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know what did Tony say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What lesson did you
learn that you're going
to immediately apply to your
life or to your business?
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join
in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to give a
quick shout out to Hugo Beyer.
Hugo, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking
that awesome picture
and posting it on Twitter.
I'm really curious to understand
what you were looking at
in that picture.
I love it, bro, and I really
appreciate the support.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- The moment when I knew I wanted to skate
and not do other sports
was the first time I went
to a skate park and saw
people flying out of pools.
All my life, I was trying to find a buzz
and I didn't really get
it from team sports.
I was okay at baseball and
basketball but I didn't,
I wasn't improving at a rate I could see
and then when I went to the
skate park for the first time,
I literally saw these guys
going into a pool and flying.
I was like, that's it!
And then I started trying to
figure out how to do that.
I did it in the little pools.
I saw a picture of Steve
Caballero who was about my size
but just a little bit
older and he was doing air
in Winchester like three or four feet out.
I saw these guys, they were
older and more experienced,
doing these things and
it looked intimidating
but it looked awesome.
When I saw Steve Caballero,
he was my size, near my age,
and he was literally
flying and I was like,
if he can do it, I can do that.
I may not do it as well as
him or with as much style
but I'm going to learn how to
do that and that was the moment.
That was the moment when I
decided I was going to do that
because I did like that
it was made me different
and it was something that
I identify myself with
and it's made me stand
apart from everyone else
I went to school with,
most other kids my age.
I did appreciate that
but at the same time,
I always wondered, well,
why don't they like this?
This is amazing.
It's super difficult.
It's adrenaline filled.
It's dangerous.
There's a sense of accomplishment.
You know, what are they
missing about this?
And it was always, it just
never really hit in those days,
and so yeah, I guess I would
be the one to either blame
or credit for doing mainstream
stuff and, hopefully,
making it acceptable
or making it authentic.
- You ever scared out there?
I mean, some of this stuff is just insane.
Are you ever kind of like
at the top of something
or about to do something and you go, geez,
I could break my neck here.
- Yeah, for sure, but that is, you know,
that's the best gauge of
should you be doing it or not?
It's more about,
for me it's about approaching
things with confidence.
If I'm going to set out to do something,
I've already convinced
myself that I can do it,
that it is possible.
If I go at it and I think,
I don't know if this is going to work,
that's when I get hurt.
- [Interviewer] That's when you get hurt.
- You know what I mean?
You can't just throw
caution to the wind and go,
well, let's see what happens
and especially at my age
and having this much experience
and having so many injuries along the way,
I'm way more methodical
about learning things.
It takes me way more
tries and I have to know
that it's going to work before
I go out and try to make it.
- [Interviewer] As a
new dad who loves sports
and wants one day to inspire my new son,
I am wondering what advice
you have that either
your Dad, Frank, gave you or
that you've given your kids.
- To do what you love doing.
Don't succumb to peer
pressure or adult pressure.
Find your voice, find
what you really enjoy,
and even if it's something
different and it's something
that's not considered cool,
if you love doing it,
you will thrive in it,
and eventually you'll be happy
because you continue to do it.
- [Interviewer] Is that what Frank --
- My Dad, you know, I
was the youngest of four,
and by the time I came
around he had seen it all
and so he's just like, go, just do it.
Whatever it is and I chose to do the most
sort of off beat thing of my siblings
but he was really supportive
in it and I was lucky in that
and that's the same kind of
approach I had to my kids.
If they love doing it,
I don't care if it's not
considered the cool thing
or if it doesn't mean that they're
going to get a varsity letter.
I want them to be happy and I
want them to enjoy themselves.